le dispararon en la cabeza y en uno de
sus brazos su delito equivocarse de
dirección ese estudiante de 16 años
afroamericano iba a recoger a sus
hermanos gemelos en Kansas City pero
llamó a la puerta equivocada el
propietario un hombre blanco de 84 años
le disparó con un revólver acusando a la
adolescente de intentar entrar en su
casa
Kelvin giglish no sobrevivió esta joven
de 20 años recibió dos disparos fatales
en el pueblo de hebrón en el estado de
Nueva York iba en su auto con tres
personas buscando una dirección Kevin de
65 años abrió fuego cuando el auto de la
joven intentaba dar un giro cerca de su
porche en Carolina del Norte Robert
Louis single disparó contra una niña de
6 años y sus padres mientras la pequeña
buscaba su pelota de baloncesto el
elemento en común armas y una
omnipresente sensación de paranoia como
que la gente está histérica hay un
elemento de estrés
y
no es Claro si hay un problema de
enfermedad mental algunos dicen que
algunos expertos hablan de que la
pandemia afecta esta agenda afectó a
esta gente que la pandemia dejó detrás
una sociedad
que nunca más será la misma
fue precisamente durante la pandemia
cuando se registró Un aumento de la
compra de armas en la Unión Americana
una situación que se une a fenómenos
como las leyes de stranger ground
defiende tu espacio presentes en más de
30 estados Son normas que respaldan el
uso de armas bajo circunstancias de
defensa propia y a las que se han
apegado algunos de los atacantes de
estos recientes tiroteos unos episodios
de violencia que han llevado a la
vicepresidenta kamala Harris a
pronunciarse las armas de guerra no
deberían estar en las calles de una
sociedad civilizada
en Texas a Pedro en Washington le
dispararon en la pierna y en la espalda
luego de que su compañera en el equipo
de porristas se subiera a un auto que
pensó que era el suyo ella al igual que
las otras víctimas sólo cometieron un
error estar en el lugar equivocado en
una nación desconfiada y Armada hasta
los dientes
[Aplausos]